herkeslere selamlar efendim ben Deniz
Mehmet hocanız matematikteki
kurtarıcınız geldi rehber matematikte
yepyeni bir temayla 9 sınıf tayfam
yolumuza devam ediyoruz hatta artık 9
sınıfın son teması bitiriyoruz 9 sınıfı
7 tema noktayı vuruyoruz sizinle
birlikte veriden olasılığa diyoruz ne
veriden olasılığa ya da kısaca olasılık
diyebiliriz son temamız bu temayla
birlikte artık kitabımızı bitiriyoruz
artık dokun sınıf müfredatını
bitiriyoruz sınavlara bomba gibi bundan
sonra yazılı kampları ile birlikte ne
yapacağız seninle birlikte
hazırlanacağız ama şimdi elimizde
kalemler önümüzde 7 tema 1 ders 9 sınıf
uygulaması için gönder gönder gelsin
hocam dedim ne anlatacaksın hocam bu
ders bak önce bazı hatırlatmalar
yapacağım ki onlar bu sayfada bu
hatırlatmaları bitireceğiz ama bizde
öyle boş geçmek yok 4 tane de soru
çözeceğiz üstüne bitmedi üstüne görece
sıklık ya da diğer adıyla deneysel
olasılık başlığını atacağız onunla
ilgili burada bir notumuz var sorularını
çözeceğiz geldik mi 11 soruya hala daha
bitmedi geldim teorik olasılığa teorik
olasılığı anlatacağım burada bunlarla
ilgili sorular çözeceğim bitmeyecek
önümüzdeki ders bu anlattıklarımın
tamamıyla ilgili sadece soru avcıları
boğacağım seni sorulara boğacağım yani o
kadar fazla soru çözeceğiz ki doğacaksın
anlaştık mı şimdi lafı cimi uzatmadan
beraber başlıyoruz bazı tanımlar var
bilmen gereken önce bu tanımlarla
başlayacağım örneğin deney nedir abi
hani sen deney yaparken ne yapıyorsun
bir şeyler deniyorsun değil mi sonuçları
gözlemlemeye çalışıyorsun sonuçlarla
gözlemlenebilen tekrarlanabilir
süreçlerdir ha deneylerin sonunda sen
her seferinde ne yapabilirsin farklı
sonuçlar elde edebilirsin mesela para
atma deneyi yapıyoruz seninle sen de not
tutuyorsun yaz diyorum ben sana para
attık hadi yazı tura geldi tura geldi
yazı geldi yaz yazı geldi tura geldi her
seferinde farklı bir şey geliyor her
deneyişimizde de farklı bir şey geliyor
buna deney adını vereceğiz geldim örnek
uzay bunlar önemli kavramlar bir deneyin
tüm olası sonuçlarının oluşturduğu
kümeye örnek uzay denir örneğin ben
elime zar aldım zarı attım kaç gelebilir
bir zarın üstünde 1'den kaça kadar
sayılar oluyordu 6'ya kadar 1 2 3 4 5 ve
6 bunlar örnek uzayın elemanlarıdır
demek ki örnek uzayım kaç elemanlı hocam
6 elemanlı ha bu arada örnek uzayın
eleman sayısını gösterirken e ile
göstereceğiz örnek uzayın kümesini
gösterirken de büyük e harfi ile
göstereceğiz anlaştık mı örnek uzay
dediğimiz o durum neymiş bir deney
sonucunda oluşabilecek tüm durumlar para
atma deneyi dik gelme şansı yok ya yazı
gelir ya tura gelir hocam işte zarar
atma deneyi ya tura gelir ya pardon ya 1
gelir 6ya kadar sayılar gelir 6 farklı
durum vardır gibi tamam mı bunlara biz
ne diyormuşuz örnek uzay elemanları
diyormuşuz peki olay nedir hocam örnek
uzayın alt kümeleridir mesela tura gelme
olayı paranın pardon zarın 3 gelme olayı
ya da ben 3 istiyorum hocam demek ki
senin olayın 3 anlaştık mı mesela not
1'den 100'e kadar notlar veriliyor ben
98 istiyorum senin olayın 98 anlaştık mı
o senin istediğin durum ya da suran
bizden istediği kısma olay adını
vereceğiz peki basit olay çıktı nedir
örnek uzayın tek bir elemanına da basit
olay çıktı adını vereceğiz şimdi bu
anlattığım kavramları öğrendik mi
öğrenmedik mi bunları buradan tekrar
edeceğim aşağıda 1'den 12'ye kadar
numaralandırılmış kartların bulunduğu
bir torba verilmiş olsun diyor soru bu
torbadan rastgele bir kart çeken Elif'in
seçtiği kartta yazan sayının çift olma
olasılığı nedir diye bir tane soru var
tamam mı ama benim sorum o değil böyle
yazılı bir soru var yukarıdaki soruda
geçen ifadelerinden hangileri olasılık
kavramlarına örnek olarak verilebilir
elif'in torbadan rastgele bir kart
çekmesi aslında bir nedir deneydir bak
buraya ne yazıyorum hocam bu olay bir
deneydir bu ifade bir deneydir torbada
12 tane kart bulunması durumu nedir
oluşabilecek deney sonundaki tüm
ihtimallerdir biz ona ne adını verdik
örnek uzayı adını verdik o zaman
buradaki arkadaşın tanımı neymiş aslında
buradaki ifade örnek uzay mesela bu
sorudaki örnek uzay kaç elemanlıdır
desem bana 12 demen lazım neye beyanen
söyledim torbada 12 tane kart var
aslında bu örnek uzayı temsil ediyor
seçilen kartın çift olması olayı aslında
bu da nedir bir olaydır arkadaşım senin
istediğin diyelim ki seçilen kartın çift
olması bak bu bir olay bizim istediğimiz
durum ya da o sonuçlardan biri tamam mı
buna da olay adını vereceğiz şimdi
gelsin bakalım 2 soru yukarıda verilen
ifadelerden hangileri doğrudur diye
sormuş bir zar atıldığında üst yüze
gelen sayının tek sayı olma durumu bir
olaydır gerçekten öyle normalde ben bir
zarı attığımda onun örnek uzayı nedir 1
2 3 4 5 6 diyelim ki benim istediğim
olayı ben A kümesi olarak göstereyim tek
sayı istiyorum 1 3 ve de 5 gelme
ihtimali işte bak bu bir olaydır örnek
uzaydan farklı istenen özel bir durumdur
evet gerçekten bu bir olaydır geç bir
kişinin kafeden kafeteryadan çay kahve
limonata arasından rastgele bir içecek
seçmesi deneyinde olay sayısı 3'tür
gerçekten buradan ne seçebilir diyelim
ki biri geliyor kafeye hocam sadece çay
alabilir değil mi değil mi geldim bir
tane içecek seçebiliyormuş bu arada
kahve alabilir kahve seçebilir veyahut
ne seçebilir limonata seçebilir
bunlardan başkasını seçemez o halde
buradan seçebileceği tane farklı olay
vardır güzel üzerinde 10 20 30 40 yazılı
4 dilimli bir çark iki kez çevrildiğinde
çarkların toplamda 50 göstermesi birden
fazla olayla gerçekleşir gerçekleşebilir
diyor şimdi 3üncü duruma bir bakalım
bakalım gerçekten üzerinde 10 yazanla 40
yazan gelirse toplamları ne yapar 10 +
40'tan cevap 50 gelir bu bir tane
olaydır bak o 40 gelme olayı pardon
toplamları 50 gelme olayı 10 ve 40
gelirse aslında 10 ve 40 diyorum ama
birincisi 40 ikincisi 10 gelmesi de
farklı bir olay olarak adlandırılır
çünkü çarkı iki kez çeviriyorsun demek
ki birinci çevirme ve ikinci çevirme
diye bir kavram var ortada bak bu da bir
olaydır ama hocam şu bir olay olmaz mı
20 ve 30 gelmesi tabii ki 20 + 30'un da
cevabı ne yapılacaktır 50 olacaktır bu
da yine bir olaydır 20 ve 30 gelme olayı
ama 30 ve 20 gelmesi de farklı bir olay
olarak adlandırılır çünkü çarkların
birincisi ve ikinci çevrilmesinden gelen
her bir durum farklı bir olayı temsil
eder bizde anlaştık mı bak burada
unutulan bazen durumlardan biridir demek
ki burada 50 göstermesi birden fazla
olayla gerçekleşebilir evet doğrudur
birden fazla olayla gerçekleşebilir
hangileri doğru hepsi doğrudur geldim
bir diğerine şimdi torbadan 1'den 8'e
kadar numaralandırılmış kartlar
bulunuyormuş bu torbadan rastgele bir
kart çekildiğinde aşağıdakilerin eee
çıktı sayılarını bulunuz benden bunu
istiyor olası tüm çıktı sayısını söyle
bana diyor yani örnek uzayı söyle diyor
örnek uzayı biz ne ile söylüyorduk hocam
şöyle veriyorduk 1'den 8'e kadar
numaralandırılmış kartlar veriliyordu
daha doğrusu burada örnek uzayı
istemiyor ama şöyle bir yazalım 4 5 6 7
8'e kadar buradaki örnek uzaydaki her
bir elemanın bir kere gelme durumunu
soruyor mesela 1 gelme durumu 2 gelme
durumu var efendime söyleyeyim 3 gelme
durumu var 4 gelme durumu var 5 gelme
durumu var 6 gelme durumu var 7 gelme
durumu var 8 gelme durumu var kaç tane
olay çıktısı var burada 8 tane değil mi
8 tane farklı durum yaşanabilir çekilen
kartın üzerindeki çift sayı yazma
olayının çıktı sayısı nedir şimdi senin
istediğinle artık özel bir durum
istiyorsun diyorsun ki burada 8 tane
kart var ben üstünde çift olanı
istiyorum 2 4 6 8 bunlardan birini
istiyorum kaç tane var 4 tane farklı
durum var değil mi tabii bunları bak
böyle toplu halde gelmiyor aslında sen
seçiyorsun diyelim ki 2 geliyor veya
seçiyorsun 4 geliyor veya seçiyorsun 6
geliyor veya kartı seçiyorsun 8 geliyor
bu durumlardan bahsediyor yani benim
oraya toplu halde yazdığıma çok da
takılma açıkçası şöyle birazcık ayağa
kalkacağım ya şöyle rahat rahat
anlatalım arkadaş dersimizi 4'ten büyük
sayı gelme olayının çıktı sayısı nedir
şimdi 4'ten büyük istiyorsun ne
gelebilir e 5 gelebilir 6 gelebilir 7
gelebilir 8 gelebilir e güzel o zaman
nedir 4 tane farklı durum vardır hocam
yola devam hem çift hem de 4'ten büyük
sayma sayı gelme olayının çıktı sayısı
hem çift istiyorsun hem de 4'ten büyük
istiyorsun şimdi 4'ten büyük dediğine
göre çift dediğine göre 6 olabilir 8
olabilir gelebilecek olay durumumuz kaç
tane oldu hop 8 tane değil tabii iki
tanedir hocam dedim iki tane farklı
durum olabilir iki tane farklı çıktı
meydana gelebilir ya hocam bunlar önemli
mi diyorsun ama olasılık
hesaplamalarında çıktı olay durumu bizim
için çok önemli çünkü olasılığı
hesaplarken ilk bulacağımız sayılardan
biri örnek uzay hemen arkasından bu
değeri bulacağız sen bana güven ben sana
aslında şu an binayı inşa ediyoruz
beraber tamam mı öyle
düşünebilirsin 8 kız 12 erkek öğrencinin
bulunduğu bir sınıfta rastgele bir tane
öğrenci seçme deneyinde cinsiyete göre
kaç çıktı vardır şimdi cinsiyete göre ya
kızlar var hocam ya da erkekler var
demek ki cinsiyete göre kaç tane çıktı
alabilirsin iki tane farklı durum elde
edebilirsin saç rengine göre çıktı
sayısı ne olabilir diyor sadece siyah
veya kahverengi saçlılar varmış demek ki
öğrenci ya siyah saçlı olabilir ya da
kahverengi saçlı olabilir kaç tane durum
var aslında yine yine iki tane farklı
durum var geldim öğrencinin kim olduğuna
göre çıktı sayısı kaçtır öğrencinin kim
olduğuna göre mi şimdi toplamda 8 k
öğrenci var 12 tane erkek öğrenci var
toplamda 20 tane öğrenci var mı o zaman
20 tane farklı kişi elde edebilirsin
öyle değil mi öğrencinin kim olduğuna
göre 20 farklı kişi var içeride o zaman
ben biri olayı oluşturmaya çalıştığımda
20 tane farklı olay elde ederim birini
seçtiğimde güzel 20 tanenin nereden
geldiğini anladık şimdi bu kısım bitti
abi burası bir nevi hatırlatma olarak
düşünebilirsin şimdi başlıyoruz görece
sıklık şimdi bu kavram birçok kaynakta
deneysel olasılık olarak adlandırılıyor
ama MEB kitabımız ısrarla üstüne burada
görece sıklık kavramını kullanıyor ama
deneysel olasılık kavramını da
kullanıyor yani sen ikisini de bilsen
iyi olur hatta birçok kaynak aslında
deneysel olasılık kullanıyor günlük
hayatta bazı olayların olma ihtimalini
tahmin ederken geçmişteki tekrar
sayıları ve geçmişteki durumları dikkate
alınıyorsa biz burada deneysel olasılık
hesaplıyoruzdur bu tür durumlarda olayın
gerçekleşme oranı göreli görele sıklık
olarak eee hesaplanır göre sıklık başka
bir adıyla deneysel olarak deneysel
olasılık olarak bilinir şimdi nedir bu
deneysel olasılık nasıl hesaplanır
dersen hani benim o bir önceki sayfada
anlattığım önemli dediğim noktalar vardı
hatırla dedim ki olayın gerçekleşme
sayısı olay sayısını bul bulduk öğrendik
bir de deneyim tekrar sayısı anlaştık mı
burada deneyin tekrar sayısını zaten
soru bana verecek bunları birbirine
böldüğümde deneysel olasılığı ya da
görli sıklığı hesaplamış olacağız
örnekle anlatınca çok kolay olacak bir
basketbol oyuncusu 50 serbest atış
yapıyor bu atışların 18 tanesi isabetli
geri kalanı ise isabetsizdir isabetli
atış gelme olayının deneysel olasılığı
kaçtır şimdi deneysel olasılık benden ne
istiyor hocam olayın gerçekleşme sayısı
bölü deneyin tekrar sayısı şimdi olayın
gerçekleşme sayısına bakın 18 tane
isabetli atabilmiş daha öncesinde demek
ki olayın gerçekleşme sayısı 18 50 tane
serbest atış yapmış toplamda demek ki
toplam deney sayısı 50 e 18/50 2'ye
böldüm ikisini de 9/25 bizim aradığımız
deneysel olasılıktır bitti bu kadar yine
aşağıya isabetsiz atış gelme olayının
deneysel olasılığı kaçtır hocam toplamda
kaç atış yaptı 50 bunlardan sadece 18
tane ise isabetli demek ki 32 tanesi
isabetsiz atış isabetsiz atış e soru da
benden isabetsiz atış gelme olayının
deneysel olasılığını soruyor deneysel
olasılık eşittir bizim durumumuz
olayımızın çıktı sayısı 32 e deney
sayısı 50 ben bunları 2'ye böldüğümde
buradan ne gelecektir 16 geldi
16/25 bizim deneysel olasılığımızdır bu
kadar devam bir öğrenci 30 kez zar
attığında 5 kez 6 sayısı 25 kez ise
farklı sayı gelmiş 6 gelme olayının
deneysel olasılığı nedir bak şimdi
deneysel olasılıkla gerçek teorik
olasılık birbirinden farklı deneysel
olasılıkta ben verileri seçerken nereye
bakmak zorundayım bana a niye yazmıyor
deminden beri yazdıklarımız gelmedi mi
şimdi mi dondu bu tövbe bismillah tıya
geçince de durdu dur bunu düzeltip
geliyorum arkadaşım hop düzelttim geldim
güzel arkadaşım kaldığımız yerden devam
o halde şimdi bir öğrenci 30 kez zar
atmış 5 kez 6 sayısı 25 kez ise farklı
sayılar gelmiş 6 gelme olayının deneysel
olasılığı kaçtır 6 gelmesini istiyorsun
6 gelen durum sayısı belli mi 5 kez
gelmiş hocam 5 kez geldi toplam deney
sayısı belli mi 30 kez atıldı demek ki
30'a böleceğim buradan da
sadeleştirdiğimde demek ki deneysel
olasılığımız 6 gelme olasılığı kaçtır
1/6'dır bak teorik olasılıkla deneysel
olasılık farklı sonuçlar verebilir aynı
sonuçları da verebilir denk gelmiş
olabilir ama burada deneysel olasılıkta
her zaman daha önceki sonuçları
izliyoruz 6 dışındaki sayıların gelme
olayının deneysel olasılığı kaçtır
deneysel olasılık eşittir 6 dışında kaç
kez farklı sayı gelmiş 25 kez toplamda
kaç tane deney yapılmış 30 keş 5'e
böldüm buradan 5 5'e böldüm buradan 6
demek ki burada da 6 sayısının haricinde
başka sayı gelme olasılığı 5/6'dır hocam
dedim 6 soru bitti 7 soruya hızla geçtim
artık bol seri şekilde teorik olasılığa
kadar soru çözeceğiz beraber aşağıdaki
tabloda Berk Elif Onur Yasemin isimli
öğrencilerin basketbol patasına
yaptıkları atışlarla ilgili deneyler
deneysel veriler verilmiştir
öğrencilerin yaptığı atış sayısı
isabetli atış sayısı aşağıdaki gibidir
atış sayıları burada isabetli atış
sayıları da yanında berk'in yaptığı
deneyde isabetli atışın deneysel
olasılığı kaçtır şimdi gel berk
hesaplamayı şöyle yazayım ben direkt
berk isabetli atışın deneysel olasılığı
isabetli atış Berk'te kaç 6 berk'in
deney sayısı kaç 30 sadeleştirdim cevap
kaç 1/5 hocam bu kadar olamaz vallahi bu
kadar elif'in yaptığı deneyde isabetli
atışın deneysel olasılığı kaçtır elif
gel bakalım elif toplamda 18 tane
isabetli atış yapmış e toplamda 60 tane
atışı var ne yaparsın 6'ya böldüm
buradan ne geldi 3 geldi buradan 6'ya
böldüm cevabım 10 geldi 3/10 olasılık
Elif'i onur'un yaptığı isabetli atışın
deneysel olasılığı kaçtır onur'a geldik
onur 10 tane toplamda 50 deneme var 10
tane isabetli toplamda 50 deneme var
cevabımız ne olacaktır Onur için
1/5 yasemin'in yaptığı deneyde isabetli
atışın deneysel olasılığı nedir diye
sormuş yasemin'e baktık dikkat et 40/80
bak en yüksek oran aslında kimde çıktı
yaseminde çıktı sadeleştirmeyi de yaptım
doğru cevabım nedir 1/2'dir şimdi burada
önemli bir durum var eee şöyle bir şey
deney sayısı arttıkça deneysel
olasılığın değeri teorik olasılığın
değerine git gide git gide yaklaşır
teorik olasılık örneğin sen bir zarı
attığında 1 gelme olasılığı 1 bir
tanedir toplamda tüm durum 6 tanedir 1/6
ama sen bir deney yaparken birin gelme
olasılığı 6 atışta daha farklı bir şey
olabilir 10 atışta farklı bir şey
olabilir deney sayısını arttırdıkça
gerçek sonuca yani teorik olasılığa git
gide git gide yaklaşan bir değer elde
edersin anlaştık mı şimdi bu da burada
bunu söylüyor zaten hani olak ki bir
yorum sorusu gelirse diye buraya not
alınmış bir bilgi bu fakat biz sorulara
devam edelim yine sayısal bir oyuncak
dükkanında mor turuncu pembe lacivert
gri renkli topların bulunduğu bir
kutudan rastgele top çekme deneyi
yapılıyor aşağıdaki grafik her bir
rengin kaç kez çekildiğini gösteriyor
kutudan toplamda kaç kez top çekilmiştir
benden bunu istiyor şimdi toplam çekilen
kutu sayısını daha doğrusu top sayısını
nereden bileceğim süt grafiğini okuyarak
anlayacaksın şuradan bak 35 tane artı
şundan kaç tane gördüm orada arada 30
tane şuradan 50 tane top çekilmiş artı
buradan da kaç tane top çekilmiş 45 tane
çekilmiş şunları bir toplayalım bakalım
hocam şuradan 80 geldi şuradan 75 geldi
şu iki arkadaşı topladım 125 geldi 75le
topladığımda toplamda 200 tane top
çekilmiş devam geldim B'ye pembe top
çekme olayının sıklığı kaçtır bir dakika
dur sıklığından kastı ne kaç defa pembe
top gelmiş bana bunu hesapla diyor bak
kaç defa pembe top gelmiş bakıyorsun
pembe burası 50 defa hocam demek ki
pembe topun sıklığı 50 ama bak bir
alttakinde neyi sorduk pembe top çekme
olayının göreli sıklığı olasılığı nedir
ha deneysel olasılığını istiyor pembenin
şimdi pembenin deneysel olasılığını
istiyorum pembenin gelme sayısı kaç 50
biz toplam kaç deney yapmıştık 200
sadeleştirmeyi yaptık cevap kaç o halde
1/4 bu kadar bu kadar bu iş gel gri top
çökme olayının göreli sıklığı kaçtır bak
olasılığını soruyor dikkat et gri top
çekme olasılığını istiyor benden toplam
kaç top var 200 top daha doğrusu 200
tane deney yapılmış bunlardan kaç tanesi
gri hocam 30 tanesi gri top gelmiş
yapıştır abim buraya 30'u gönder bunları
3/20 kalmaz mı cayır cayır kalır bitti
bu kadar sen var ya sen bitirdin bu işi
ya devam devam şimdi tane daha deneysel
olasılık sorum var yalnız bu soruları da
bitirdikten sonra teorik olasılığı da
anlatacağım öyle hemen bir yere kaçma
öyle kısa bir ders olmayacak haliyle
uzun bir ders olacak ama hakkını
verdiğimiz ders olacak gel bakalım şimdi
şimdi geldik 9 soruya bir kaleci bir
maçta bir yarı boyunca kalesine gelen 8
şutun 6ı'sını kurtarmış ikisi gol
olmuştur bir dakika şimdi ne var
elimizde 8 tane şut var hocam bunlardan
6 tanesi ne oldu kurtarış oldu kurtarış
yazdık bunlardan iki tanesi ne oldu gol
oldu buna göre ikinci yarı kalesine
gelen ilk şutun gol olma olasılığının
deneysel olarak değeri kaçtır yani
deneysel olasılığını soruyor nasıl
hesaplıyorduk benden ne istiyor gol
olanların olasılığını istiyor deneysel
hocam daha önce iki tane gol olmuş
toplamda 8 tane deney yapılmış
sadeleştirmeyi yaptığımızda cevabımız ne
olacaktır 1/4 bu kadar geç hızlıca bir
zar 8 defa havaya atılmış üst yüze 4
defa tek 4 defa çift sayı gelmiştir
deneysel olasılık hesabına göre bundan
sonraki 9 atışta zarın üst yüzüne tek
sayı gelme olasılığı kaçtır şimdi
şuradaki cümle belki kafanı karıştırır
hocam 9 tane mi atış yapıldı hayır şimdi
ben 9 atışı yapacağım ya yapacağım bu
atışta artık deneysel olasılığa göre
konuşabilirim bu olasılıkta ne gelmesini
istiyorum tek sayı daha önce kaç defa
tek gelmiş 4 defa tek gelmiş daha önce
kaç defa deney yapılmış 8 defa yapılmış
o halde oran kaç 1/2 bu kadar denesel
olasılık gerçekten kolay bu da onun son
sorusu tarihsel ve doğal mirasa
duyarlılık kapsamında yapılan ankete
1400 kişiye bugüne kadar bir müzeyi
ziyaret edip etmedikleri sorulmuş alınan
cevaplar ise aşağıdaki kutuda
gösterilmiştir erkeklerin ve kadınların
ziyaret edip etmeme sayıları burada
yapılan deneyde cevap veren bir kişinin
işte kritik cümle hayır diyen bir kadın
ya da evet diyen bir erkek olma
olasılığını bulunuz şimdi bak iki tane
durumu bir arada istiyorum hayır diyen
yani ziyaret edilmeyen ziyaret edilen
ziyaret edilmeyen 300 kişi yani
kadınlarda hayır diyen evet diyen
erkekler 400 kişi soru benden ne yapmamı
istiyor hayır diyen bir kadın veya ya da
ne olmasını istiyor hayır diyen
kadınların sayısı yalnız 300 veya bu
arada Silgiye ne olmuş öyle ya tövbe ya
Rabbim silginin boyu çok uzamış veya
evet diyen bir erkek olma olasılığı
300'e + 400 peki bizim burada kaç tane
durumumuz var kaç kişiye biz soru
sormuşuz bakalım hemen şunları topladım
buradan 900 kişi şunları topladım
buradan 500 kişi toplam ne yaptı 1400
kişi yaptı gerçekten de 1400 kişiydi
toplamda biz 700 kişiden hayır diyen bir
kadın ya da evet diyen bir erkek olayını
gördük şunları sadeleştirdik cevabımız
ne geldi 1/2 geldi noktayı vurduk burayı
bitirdik ama ders bitmedi devam devam
devam devam teorik olasılık bununla
ilgili yine ayrıntılı dersim devam
edecek bir sonraki derste de yine
buradan konu olarak da devam ediyor
olacağız teorik olasılık olası tüm
çıktılar düşünülerek hesaplanır yani
burada teorik olasılıkta daha önce gelen
sonuçlara bakılmaz acaba hangi sonuçlar
gelebilir ona bakılır istenen durumların
sayısının tüm olası durumların sayısına
oranı alınır ve cevap bulunur bütün
olasılık mevzusu aslında bunun üstüne
kurulu lütfen burayı aklından çıkarma
bir olayın olma olasılığı istenen olayın
çıktı sayısı bölü tüm durum istenen bölü
tüm istenen bölü tüm istenen bölü tüm
istenen bölü tüm benimle birlikte söyle
isten böyle tüm hocam istenem böyle tüm
hocam benimle birlikte söylüyorsun
istenem böyle tüm durum bitti bu kadar
biz aslında olasılığı bir fonksiyon
olarak alıyoruz ve bir olayın olma
olasılığını genelde PA gibi bir değerle
göstereceğiz p olayının olasılığı a bir
olay bizim istediğimiz PA bu olayın olma
olasılığı şimdi bir zar atıldı 2 gelme
olasılığı kaçtır ne yapacağım olası tüm
durumları bulacağım olası tüm durumlar 1
2 3 4 5 6 değil mi tüm durumların
sayısını nereye yazıyorduk 6 2 gelme
olasılığı bu 6 sayıda kaç defa mümkün
bir defa mümkün o zaman cevabım kaç 1/6
bu olasılık 1/6'dır devam 5 gelme
olasılığı kaçtır hocam bak 6 tane sayı
var toplamda 5 gelme olasılığı kalkıp
buraya 5 yazmıyorsun o 5 kartı
çektiğinde zarı attığında özür dilerim
kaç defa gelebiliyor bir defa gel değil
mi bir ihtimalle gelebilir benim
istediğim bir tane durum yukarıda
onların tüm durumları 6 tane 1/6
olasılık devam aşağıda içinde şekiller
dışında tamamen özdeş olan kalp yıldız
kare şeklinde objelerin bulunduğu bir
kutu verilmiştir buna göre bu kutudan
rastgele seçilen bir objenin kalp olma
olasılığı kaçtır şimdi sana her zaman
örnek uzayın elemanları lazım örnek uzay
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 toplamda kaç
tane eleman var 11 tane eleman var o
zaman tüm durumların sayısı kaçtır
diyeceksin 11'dir kalp olma olasılığı
kaç tane kalp var hocam 3 tane kalp olma
olasılığı o zaman 3/11 yıldız olma
olasılığı dikkat et kaç tane yıldız var
4 istenen bölü tüm durum aklından asla
çıkarmıyorsun istenen durum 4 tane hocam
e tüm durum 11 tane cevap 4/11 kare olma
olasılığı hocam oradan da bak 4 tane var
o zaman istenen bölü tüm durum 4/11 de
buradan yazarsın 13'ün soruyu bitirir
gönder gelsin 14 dersin koca bir sayfa
soru yanlısı derece tayfa mı yoksa değil
değil daha derece tayfa sorularına
gelmedik onları da soracağız ama ileride
aşağıda 15 parçaya ayrılmış bir çark
verilmiş çarkın her bölmesine 1'den 10'a
kadar sayılar yazılmış çark
çevrildiğinde okun ucunun gösterdiği
sayının çift sayı olma olasılığı kaçtır
şimdi soru benden çift sayı olma
olasılığını istiyor ama bir dakika
durduruyorum önce benim örnek uzaya
karar vermem lazım yani oluşabilecek tüm
durumlar nelerdir hocam bak 1 gelir 2
gelir 3 gelir 4 gelir 5 gelir 6 gelir 7
gelir 8 gelir 9 gelir 10 gelebilir doğru
mu istenen durum olay nedir çift sayı
çift sayılar hangileri 2
4 8 ve 10 şimdi geldim buraya tüm durum
kaç tane 10 tane istenen kaç tane 5 tane
çift sayı gelme olasılığı kaçmış 1/2 bu
kadar her zaman şunu yapıyorsun istenen
bölü istenen bölü tüm durum diyorsun
bunu yazdığında karşında olasılık sarısı
durmuyor asal sayı olma olasılığı kaçtır
bak senin istediklerine B diyelim biz
asal sayılar kaçtır kendisine ve 1'e
bölün birden başka kendisinden ve 1den
başka pozitif böleni olmayan sayılara
asal sayılar diyorduk doğal sayılara 2 3
5 7 Badaki asal sayılar peki asal sayı
kaç tane 4 yani sen 4 tane durumu
istiyorsun ama burada kaç tane sayı var
10 tane ufak bir de sadeleştirme
yaptığında demek ki bu olasılık değeri
kaçmış 2/5 5'ten büyük olma olasılığı
diyelim ki senin istediklerine C kümesi
5'ten büyük istiyorsun 6 7 8 9 bir de 10
gelebilir 5'ten büyük senin normalde kaç
tane durum var 10 istediğin kaç tane
durum var 5 sadeleştirmeyi yaptın cevap
kaç 1/ 2'dir 1 veya 10 olma olasılığı
şimdi bunu nasıl hesaplayacağız 1 veya
10 yani senin istediğin kümenin
içerisinde 1'i veya 10'u istiyorsun
güzel kaç tane çark var bir kere
çeviriyorum 10 tane durum var 10 tane
durum gelebilir bir çevirmede bizim
istediğimiz kaç tane 2 tane
sadeleştirmeyi yaptık olasılık kaç 1/5
anlıyorsun değil mi 4 ile 9 arası dahil
olma olasılığı kaçtır bak 4 ile 9 4 5 6
7 8 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 tane sayı var sen 6
sayı istiyorsun ama toplamda çarkı
çevirdiğinde 10 tane durum var bunları
sadeleştirdiğimde cevap ne olacaktır
3/5 olacaktır işte bu kadar ya yani
istenen böyle tümü yazdıktan sonra
aslında dediğim gibi teorik olasılığın o
temel sorularında soru kaçırmıyorsun
diyor şimdi o temel sorulara da devam
bir kutuda bulunan 12 özdeş topun 4'ü
kırmızı 5'i yeşil 3ü mor renklidir bu
kutudan rastgele alınan bir topun
kırmızı olma olasılığı nedir bir kere
toplamda kaç top var 12 tane özdeş top
var biz kırmızı istiyoruz bak mesela
kırmızı olasılığını istiyorum hocam 12
top var 4'ü kırmızı bunların 4/12 o oran
kaç oldu 1/3 demek ki olasılığım 1/3'müş
bu kutudan rastgele alınan bir topun mor
olma olasılığı mor olasılığını istiyorum
tüm durum kaç tane bu değişmedi bu hala
12 tane peki mor kaç taneydi hocam 3
taneydi sadeleştirmeyi yaptım cevap kaç
geldi 1/4 geldi bu kutudan rasgele
alınan bir topun yeşil veya kırmızı olma
durumu şimdi yeşil veya kırmızı olma
durumu dediğimde yeşilden kaç tane var
içeride 5 tane kırmızıdan kaç tane var 4
tane senin istediğin kaç tane top var
aslında içeride 9 tane toptan birini
istiyorsun yeşil veya kırmızı kırmızı da
gelse üzülmeyeceksin yeşil de gelse
üzülmeyeceksin e o zaman bu olasılığı
hesaplarken senin istediğin durum 9 tane
e tüm durum kaç taneydi 12 taneydi
yukarıda 3'e böldüm 3 3'e böldüm 4 demek
ki oranımız kaç olacaktır
3/4 gönder gelsin sıradaki gönder gelsin
hocam gaza geldik artık bir kütüphanede
kitaplar konusu ve cilti bakımından
sınıflandırılmış kitapların sayıca
dağılımı aşağıdaki tabloda verilmiş
kütüphaneden rastgele seçilen bir
kitabın bak nasıl olmasını istiyorsun
beraber okuyalım orayı bir kitabın bilim
konulu ve sert kapaklı olma olasılığı
şimdi bilim konulu olmasını istiyorum
baktım bilim konulu dediğinde nereyi
işaretliyorum burayı işaretliyorum sert
kapaklı olmalı dediğine göre nereyi
işaretliyorum burayı işaretliyorum peki
hem bilim konulu hem sert kapakla çünkü
V bağlacı var arada yani ikisinin de
olduğu durumu istiyor benden hem bilim
konulu hem sert kapaklı olan ve sert
kapaklı olan fark etmez 4 tane peki
hocam bizim istediğimiz durum 4 e burada
rastgele seçilen bir kitap diyor o zaman
tüm kitapların sayısı gerekli sana
mesela bak sert kapaklı kitapların
sayısı 10 tane şunları topladığımda 20
tane 10 kitap oradan 20 kitap oradan
toplamda 30 tane kitap var tüm durum
kaçmış 30'muş buna dikkat tüm durum 30
rastgele seçilen bir kitap diyor
rastgele bir kitap seçtim 30 tane kitap
var benim istediğim orada sert kapaklı
bilim kitabı o da 4 tane sadeleştirmeyi
yaptım cevabım
2/15 güzel soruydu 17 soru 25 doldurduk
ama örneğe boğduk burada seni 25 kişilik
bir sınıfta öğrencilerin 14'ü erkek 11'i
kız öğrencidir kız öğrencilerin 6'sı
erkek öğrencilerin 9'u fen bilimleri
dersinden geçmiştir şimdi bak bunları da
yerlerine yazalım çünkü aşağıdaki
tabloda verilere göre de doldurun diyor
25 kişilik bir sınıf 25 kişilik dediğine
göre şuraların kutuların toplamı 25 kişi
yapacak bir kere 14'ü erkekmiş demek ki
burada 14 tane erkek var 11 tane ne var
kız öğrenci var gerçekten 14 11 daha
25'i bana veriyor hocam kız öğrencilerin
6'sı erkek öğrencilerin 9'u fen
bilimleri dersinden geçmiş fen bilimli
dersinden geçenler 9 6 tane kız öğrenci
9 tane erkek öğrenci şimdi bir dakika
erkekler 14 kişiydi 9'u fenden geçtiyse
yaz hemen buraya 5 yapıştır bak burada
ne var 11 6 tanesi burada hocam aa bu da
5 yok bütün tabloyu doldurdun artık soru
benden ne istiyor ona bakalım fen
dersinden kalan öğrencinin kız öğrenci
olma olasılığı nedir şimdi biz rastgele
bir öğrenci seçiyoruz ya rastgele
seçilen bir öğrencin rastgele seçtiğim
yerde kaç öğrenci var 25 tüm durum 25
ben kalan kız öğrenci olmalı olasılığı
kalan kız öğrenci kaç kişi fen dersinden
kalan kız öğrenci 5 kişi o zaman 5/25
sadeleştirmeyi yaptım o zaman 1/5
olasılı fen dersinden geçen erkek
öğrenci olma olasılığı tüm durum belli
bunda bir değişiklik yok yine 25 kişi
var biz bu sefer geçen erkek öğrencileri
istiyoruz geçen erkek öğrenci sayısı kaç
9 sadeleştirme olmuyor bu yine 9/25
olarak kalıyor erkek ya da fen dersinden
of bak bu güzel işte erkek ya da fen
dersinden kalan bir öğrenci olmalı erkek
ya da fen dersinden kalan hocam
kesişimimi alacağım hayır arada ya da
bağlacı var erkek ya da fen dersinden
kalma bunların tamamını istiyorsun sen
aslında kim gelirse gelsin üzülmezsin
çünkü erkek ya da fen dersinden
kalanların sayısı burası şimdi olasılığı
nasıl hesaplayacağım tüm durum kaç tane
25 dersine 25 tane erkek ya da fen dersi
deyip kalanların sayısı deyip yaptığım
yer neresi şu sarı bölge 9 5 daha 14 14
5 daha ne yaptı 19 yaptı senin istediğin
durum 19 tane düm durum 25 tane seni
burada belki de soru olarak tek
zorlayacak kısım bence burada C şıkkıydı
buradaki C şıkkını anladıysam vallahi
var ya sınavda da gelecek soruyu
tokatlarız diye düşünüyorum ama bir
sonraki ders böyle yarma gül gibi soru
çözeceğiz hiç merak etme yani kolay
sorular da olacak içerisinde hatta önce
kolaylarla başlayacağız ama bol bol sana
pratik yaptıracağım iyice böyle hafızayı
işleyeceğiz bence günün güzel
sorularından biri hani derece tayfa
diyebileceğim sorularından biri bir
bakalım beraber soruya bir okulda
öğrenciler okulları yürüyerek bisikletle
ya da özel araçla gitmektedir şimdi
okula yürüyerek giden var neyle var
bisikletle giden var bir de özel araçla
gidenlerin sayısı var henüz o sayılar
verilmedi okula bisikletle giden öğrenci
sayısı yürüyerek giden öğrenci sayısının
3 katıdır hemen notunu al yürüyerek
giden sayısının 3 katıymış bisikletle
gidenler x yürüyerek gidenlerse e
bisikletle gidenler onun 3 katıymış öyle
değil mi
3x bu okulda rastgele seçilen bir
öğrencinin okula özel araçla gelme
olasılığı 1/4'tür bu okulda rastgele bir
öğrenci seçeceğiz bir dakika buraya y
diyelim şimdi tüm öğrenci sayısına ne
dersin tüm öğrenciler tüm öğrenci
sayısına y buradan 3x 1x de buradan 4x
4x + y midir olasılık hesaplıyorsun
diyorsun ki rastgele seçilen bir
öğrencinin okula özel araçla gelme
durumu yani özel araçla gelenlerin
sayısının tüm öğrenci sayısına bölümü
kaçmış 1/4'müş bana bu olasılık değerini
vermiş bu yüzden ilginç bir soru peki
hocam bizim elimizde ne var özel araçta
gelenlerin sayısı y'dir tüm öğrencilerin
sayısını az önce yazdık 4x + y'dir artık
buradan ne yapacağım işlem yapmaya
çalışacağım hemen işlemi yaptım içler
dışlar 4y = 4x + y hemen y'leri bir
tarafa topladım 3y = 4x gibi bir şey
elde ettim dursun burada soru neyi
soruyor ona bakalım beraber buna göre
okula yürüyerek gelen öğrenci sayısı
özel araçta gelen öğrenci sayısının kaç
katıdır yani şunu istiyor yürüyerek
gelen öğrenci bir dakika yazamadım
yürüyerek gelen öğrenci yürüyerek
yürüyerek gelen öğrenci ve özel araçta
gelenlerin oranını istiyor bir nevi
bizden kısaca yürüyerek gelenlere x
demiştin hocam özel araçta gelenlere y
demiştin x/ Y oranı buranın cevabı
olacak hocam x/ Y'yi bulmak için ne
yaparsın y'yi buraya bölüm olarak
atarsın 4'ü de karşıya bölüm olarak
atarsın kısaca 3/4 sana neyi verir x/ Y
oranını verir o halde cevabım ne
olacaktır 3/4 olmalıdır dedim vurdum
cevabı derece tayfa tadında gerçekten
lezzetli gerçekten mülk bir soruyla 18
soruyu devirdik burada kolay değil
gerçekten hani böyle hakkını vere vere
tanımıyla kavramıyla ispatıyla ama en
önemlisi matematiğin mantığıyla
öğrenerek ilerliyoruz inşallah böyle son
güne kadar da devam edeceğiz ilk günden
beri takip eden tayfa zaten biliyor
şimdi önemli bir duyuru sizler için çok
özel bir kamp geliyor 9 sınıflar 10
sınıflar 11 sınıflar herkes katılabilir
sıfırdan matematik kampı yapacağız
matematikteki eksiklerimizin tamamını bu
kampla birlikte gidereceğiz ne zaman 1
Haziran'da başlıyor ardından da 49 günde
TYT matematik kampı başlayacak ki o da
ne zaman olacak 1 Temmuz 7 senedir hatta
8 senedir yapıyorum o kampı da muhakkak
o kampı da görmende fayda var ama senin
için önemlisi şimdilik 1 Haziran kampı
ne olur bu kampa katılmemek
eksiklerimizi temel matematik
eksikliklerimizi tamamen burada
bitireceğiz anlaştık mı Ayfam 9 sınıfı
halledeceğiz rahat ol sınavlardan yüksek
kalacağız hiç merak etme ama matematiği
bir toparlamamız gerekiyor diyorsan 1
Haziran'daki kampa beklerim efendim
kendine çok iyi bak bir sonraki derste
görüşelim ınstagram'dan takip etmeyi
unutma oradan da yine duyuruları yapmaya
devam edeceğim hoş kal hoşça kal
[Müzik]